CDC director dr. Robert Redfield
considers the opioid epidemic the public
health crisis of our time preliminary
CDC data shows the number of deadly drug
overdoses nationwide has plateaued for
six straight months still more than
72,000 Americans died last year from
drug overdoses a little over 48 thousand
of those deaths were from opioids we
spoke to dr. Redfield about why the
crisis hits close to home for him he
also explains how the CDC is ready to
expand its research into the causes of
gun violence but is waiting for Congress
to provide the money to do so in terms
of priorities the Secretary of HHS said
that he would instruct the CDC to to
conduct research on the causes of gun
violence has he done that we have a
program called the national violent
surveillance system and so we currently
are recording violent deaths from all
causes including firearms and so that is
that's ongoing what in your mind
constraints are there from the Dickey
amendment I I don't feel we have any
restrictions to do research the issue
will be if Congress can give us funding
to expand the research that we're
currently able to do the Secretary has
also made it clear that we do not have a
restriction to do research it basically
what we need to do is get a funding
mechanism for Congress to instruct us to
do that research if you were doing that
priority list how high up on the list
would the causes of gun violence be when
you're asking for money and saying you
know we need the money to do the proper
amount of research well I think it's
it's it's in the mix you'll find at CDC
our programs are largely driven by where
Congress puts the priority don't want to
fund us you're not silent in that
conversation you could say there are
tens of thousands of deaths in America
that result from this we'd like some
money to know how to be able to actually
I think people know that we're poised to
be able to do research in this area if
Congress chose us chooses to give us
additional funding CDC has released some
preliminary data on opioid overdose
deaths it seems to maybe plateaued
what's where are we right now you know
that we had over 72,000 people died last
year from drug overdose a little over 48
thousand of them
opioids it's gonna require enormous
effort to get this epidemic under
control is it that we don't know how to
attack the problem or that we don't know
how to execute a plan to go after it
well I think first and foremost we have
to recognize it for what it is it's a
medical condition it's not a moral
failing all right the second thing we
have to recognize is it's actually a
chronic medical condition it's personal
to me I think you know one of my six
children almost died from cocaine that
was contaminated with fentanyl you know
I try to encourage people to support
families like us that are trying to win
the battle against opioid addiction
recognize that treatment success is
possible you should become the rule not
the exception you know I think my wife
and I have a very supportive family but
my own son was in tears when he finally
told us that he was using cocaine and I
didn't understand you know why didn't
come earlier well because he was made to
feel the shame you know who knows why
started using cocaine you know we now
know that two to six percent of people
they get a single prescription for an
opioid like for a wisdom tooth or
something become chronically dependent
there's that pathophysiological reason
for addiction and the more we can
embrace that not make people feel bad
about it you know we don't make people
feel bad if they have cancer we have to
allow people to embrace the medical
illnesses they have and help them get
the best therapy treatment so that they
can go on to a productive and happy life
you know the point he was making is
reducing the stigma for people with an
opioid condition and that's important
for those with it but also we talked
about you know my own kids creating the
conditions for conversations so that if
this happens in your family you don't
have a situation where you say oh my
gosh where did this come from
well it's a big help removing the stigma
when the head of CDC says listen it
happened to me yeah that's a very brave
of him to show did you know that going
in that he had that in his family yeah
but he was you're right though and he
but he is really anxious to get the
message out there because his is you
know he really wants to be a to get
people to understand that changing the
stigma is important another thing he
said is fortune 500 companies are as
important as the medical field because
they can provide jobs because it's so
difficult when if you have this can
getting treatment and then getting back
into a productive job that gives your
life meaning so that you don't seek it
from other places reminder that he like
so many others have two jobs right yes
job the CDC and then its most important
job as a parent you got it